the government's top ethics watchdog is
calling it quits after repeated clashes
with the Trump administration Walter
Shaw is stepping down as director of the
Office of government ethics he made the
announcement yesterday in a letter to
President Trump Shaab writes that
government officials must quote place
loyalty to the Constitution laws and
ethical principles above private gain
Julianna Goldman spoke to shop just
after his resignation she is in
Washington Julianne good morning good
morning Walter Schwab was nominated by
President Obama in his five-year tenure
was set to end in January and as he very
publicly took on the new president who
is also his new boss he wasn't sure if
ultimately he'd be fired being able to
say we're not criminals isn't enough for
government officials Walter Shaw is
cutting short his tenure as the top
ethics watchdog because he says he can't
compel the current White House to go
beyond the bare minimum of ethical
standards
my current experience with this
administration has taught me that the
ethics program needs to be stronger than
it is he told us that unless President
Trump eliminates all financial ties to
his businesses the American people can
never be certain his policy decisions
are based on what's best for the country
do you think the president and his
family are using the office to enrich
themselves I can't know what their
intention is I know that the effect is
that there's an appearance that the
businesses are profiting from his
occupying the presidency Schaub cited
the president's frequent visits to his
own properties like the Trump
International Hotel just blocks from the
White House why is it problematic for
the president to visit his properties
the definition of corruption that's
accepted internationally by most people
who study the issue is abusive entrusted
authority and so you don't want to be
appearing to abuse your authority by
having by creating opportunities to
advertise your own financial interests
he told us he attempted to raise the
issue with mr. Trump's legal team in
late November before the inauguration
the counsel to the president shouted us
down when we tried to communicate that
message my two sons who are right here
are going to be running the company
again I don't have to do this as mr.
Trump noted in January there are no
conflict of interest laws for a
president but his attorney gave another
reason why he wasn't going to sell off
his assets he'd lose money I have no
sympathy for that I mean he's in a
position where he's going to have to
send young men and women to die in
combat potentially or risk their lives
at least so no it's not too much to ask
for somebody to incur a bit of a
financial loss if they have to sell
things off in a statement to CBS News
the White House said the president works
closely with outside counsel to ensure
that there are no conflicts of interest
Norah
all right Julianna thank you so much